[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
grand comme le Royaume-Uni le Laos
partage ses frontières avec la Chine la
Birmanie la Thaïlande le Cambodge et le
Vietnam communiste depuis 1975 le Laos
sort peu à peu de l'isolement et s'ouvre
au tourisme une manne providentielle
pour ces 5 millions d'habitants
essentiellement bouddhiste vivant avec
un salaire moyen de 1 dollar par
jour pendant la guerre du Vietnam le
Laos qui n'était pourtant pas en conflit
avec les États-Unis a beaucoup souffert
des bombardements le long de la piste
hosimine cette guerre secrète a fait
plus de 400000 victimes pour lui venir
en aide les pays occidentaux ont financé
à partir de la fin des années 60 la
création d'un barrage hydroélectrique à
une soantaine de kilomètres de la
capitale
vientian les résultats sont probants
l'hydroélectricité est aujourd'hui
devenu l'une des premières ressources du
pays avec l'exportation de
bois la construction du barrage de
namgou s'est faite en trois phases à
partir de 197 jusqu 1971 ont été mis en
place les équipements électriques c'est
pendant cette première phase que le lac
a été
créé pour l'intérêt commun le Laos
produit de l'électricité au barrage de
namgou pour que le peuple laosien
l'utilise dans la vie quotidienne et
surtout dans la capitale
vientian après on achemine l'électricité
au nord du pays jusqu'à Luang Prabang on
en vend aussi une grosse partie à la
Thaïlande au sud cette richesse
naturelle nous permet ainsi de gagner
des devises
étrangères avec le développement du pays
on prévoit de construire de nouveaux
barrages dans les 10 ans à
venir avec la construction du barrage
toute une vallée a été noyée sous des
millions de mètres cubes d'eau donnant
naissance au lac de
namgou avant le lac il y avait ici un
village avec une trentaine de maisons
quand le gouvernement a créé le barrage
il y a eu d'énormes inondations la
population qui habitait dans la vallée a
dû se réfugier sur le bord du
[Musique]
lac avant les travx du barrage
il y avait d'im fort dans la vallée on y
trouvait des tigres des éléphants et des
crocodiles avec l'inondation toutes les
forêts se sont retrouvé sous les EAU le
gouvernement n'avait pas eu le temps ni
les moyens de déboiser tout le bois est
donc rest sous l'eau les gens ont dû
abandonner leur maison et leur
[Musique]
champs d'près les études il que le lac
mesure km
car pour les îles on n pas encore
renseigné ce n'est pas vraiment officiel
peut-être qu'il y en a 3000 ou 4000 en
tout cas il y en a très peu
d'habités à la création du lac
artificiel de namgou la région abritait
des factions rebelles sans sommation les
villages et les forêts furent
inondé
le Laos ne possède aucun accès à la mer
les gens de la région paysans pour la
plupart ignoraient tout des activités
aquatiques le gouvernement finança même
un programme pour importer des variétés
de poissons et créer un secteur de pêche
sans succès jamais à cour d'idée les
autochtones découvrirent au début des
années 80 une autre activité lucrative
la coupe du bois car le lac est un
véritable
gisement des milliers d'arbres immerg at
désormais toutes les convoitises
âgé de plusieurs centaines d'années ils
ont continué de pousser sous l'eau la
putréfaction n'est que superficielle le
cœur des arbres lui est resté
[Musique]
intact il nous est utile de couper les
trons d'arbres car les branches et les
déchets se M dans nos turbines et stoppe
la production
d'électricité on a donc besoin de
nettoyer ce lac en plus ça permettrait
d'enlever l'odeur de pourriture des
arbres en décomposition le bois coupé
permet aussi de fabriquer des meubles et
d'autres objets et ça c'est utile pour
le peuple
laoien depuis que le gouvernement a
autorisé la coupe du bois ça s'est
beaucoup modernisé et j'ai même entendu
dire que maintenant ils utilise des
hommes grenouilles pour pêcher le bois
je crois que c'est un des seuls endroits
au monde où l'on va chercher du bois
sous l'eau
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
les bûcherons attendent la saison sèche
pour couper les trons d'arbres
à cette période le niveau du lac descend
de plus de 10
m la première étape avant la coupe est
le repérage des meilleures
[Musique]
souches une équipe de plongeurs descend
à la recherche des plus belles essences
de bois à de grandes
profondeur
[Musique]
lo je nage en faisant très attention
j'observe bien si j'aperçois des plantes
ou des branches de bois que je dois
éviter
quand l'eau devient trop sombre je ne
vois pas bien alors j'essaie de nager
tout doucement en
tâonnant quand je suis très profond et
que je ne vois rien je remonte jusqu'à
un endroit plus
clair dans l'eau il y a trois niveaux un
premier niveau à environ 5 m l'eau est
très claire ensuite l'eau devient très
dense presque noire au trè niveau tout
au fond du lac vers 40 50 m l'eau
redevient très
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
claire
[Musique]
par là-bas il y a plein d'anciennes
maisons sous l'eau tout ces anciennes
habitations ne tiennent plus en place
les murs s'écroulent on voit juste les
poutres les toit ont disparu depuis bien
longtemps je vois souvent la pagode il y
a un grand Boudha en béton juste
devant au fond de l'eau il reste encore
plein d'objets des villages
d'avant mais moi je n'ose pas en prendre
pour les remonter car j'ai peur des
objets
anciens lorsqu'un plongeur a repéré un
Tron d'arbre en bon état il pose une
marque une bouteille en plastique relié
au fond indique à la barge de découpe
l'endroit où envoyit le
trononneur
moi j'aimerais être plongeur comme eux
et aussi couper le bois pour ça je
m'entraîne tous les
jours il faut que je m'exerce comme ça
quand les autres seront vieux je
pourrais prendre le
place
avant sur le lac il y avait une
cinquantaine de bateaux pour couper les
bois plein de petites entreprises
individuelles et de petits commerçants
travaill en même
temps depuis que le gouvernement a
changé les lois il ne reste que 9 ou 10
bateaux qui peuvent investir ici mais
ils doivent tous vendre à la même
entreprise
[Musique]
la coupe de bois commence toujours par
le même rituel le bûcheron sur se
concentre un long moment avant de
plonger dans les profondeurs du
lac ses coéquipiers vérifient le bon
fonctionnement de la tronçonneuse et du
compresseur qui permet de respirer sous
[Musique]
l'eau
j'utilise l'énergie hydraulique du
bateau la pression est envoyée par les
câbles et lorsque j'appuie sur le bouton
la tronçonneuse se met en
marche je dois la manier avec précaution
c'est très
dangereux rentrer en permanence sinon on
peut se
[Musique]
couper
les bûcherons du lac prennent tous les
risques pour gagner leur
vie leur matériel de plongée est
rudimentaire et lors des plongées
profondes ils ne prennent jamais le
temps de faire les paliers de
[Musique]
décompression à chaque plongée ils
mettent leur vie en
[Musique]
péril les ouvriers gagnent à peu près 25
dollars par mois pour ceux comme moi qui
coupe et trouve le bois on gagne tro
fois
plus un chargement de bois tendre
rapporte 5 dollars en plus on gagne
encore plus avec un chargement complet
de bois dur comme le bois de rose là
c'est le double
[Musique]
ce métier est très dangereux car on peut
risquer la mort mais ça en vaut la peine
on touche un bon salaire surtout si on
tombe sur une belle
souche
[Musique]
le premier bateau sert pour la coupe du
bois il alimente en énergie la
tronçonneuse et fourn l'air pour les
plongeurs la petite barque elle amène
les plongeurs pour la recherche des bois
le trè bateau lui est une barche qui
permet de ramener le chargement jusqu'au
bord du
lac
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on a eu du bon bois du bois de rose
surtout la barge est presque
pleine c'est bien vous dirit décharger
demain ok
compris maintenant ils s'en vont mesurer
les Tron de bois de rose et de padouque
ce sont des bois dur et solides de très
bonne qualité aujourd'hui cétait une
bonne journée ils en ont trouvé
[Applaudissements]
beaucoup pour couper le bois dans le lac
de namgou ça coûte beaucoup plus cher
que dans la forêt ça représente un gros
investissement avant on était bien plus
nombreux maintenant il ne reste plus
qu'une dizaine de
bateaux en fait tous ceux qui n'ont pas
investi dans du matériel moderne on fait
fa moi j'ai dépensé beaucoup d'argent
dans la tech de plonger en plus je dois
entretenir plusieurs bateaux et payer
les salaires des hommes grenouill j'ai
eu du mal à trouver des gens qui savent
plonger et nager c'est assez dangereux
les gens qui coupent le bois dans le
fond du lac risquent leur vie beaucoup
plus que ceux qui coupent le bois en
[Musique]
forêt
nous sommes en train de faire les
comptes on fait ça à la fin de chaque
journée en fait je note les rondins de
bois que chaque plongeur a trouvé en
tout nous sommes TR plongeurs et je
calcule le nombre de mètres cubes pour
chacun il faut tout mesurer pour savoir
combien on va gagner par exemple
aujourd'hui a trouvé 25 m C de rondin on
calcule combien de dollars ça lui
fera
[Musique]
les bûcherons devront passer une nuit de
plus sur leur embarcation au confort
rudimentaire chaque mission dure 2
semaines 15 jours sans poser le pied à
terre sans voir leur famille rester dans
les villages
[Musique]
environnants
une fois le bateau barge chargé les deux
embarcations se séparent tous les
rondins de bois pêchés sous l'eau sont
acheminés par les plus jeunes vers les
rives du
[Musique]
lac
les mousses de l'équipage sont âgés de
14 à 17 ans ils sont chargés de livrer
la précieuse cargaison de bois au
débarcadaire situé près du principal axe
routier au nord du
laut ce lieu de déchargement est distant
d'une quinzaine de kilomètres de la zone
des forêts
immergées je travaille depuis 10 ans
dans le secteur du bois je pense que
dans quelques années il ne restera plus
beaucoup de bois exploitable au fond de
l'eau d'ici là je pourrais peut-être
recycler mes bateaux dans le tourisme ou
la pêche si ces activités se développent
mais pour l'instant je vends du bois à
l'entreprise làhaut aussi c'est cette
entreprise qui transforme le bois brut
avant de exp vers
l'étranger le gouvernement laoien a cédé
en
1990 l'exploitation du bois du lac à une
seule
entreprise la société là aussi a
aujourd'hui le monopole sur la filière
du bois du lac de
namgou la qualité du bois sous-marin est
supérieure à celle des forêts sous l'eau
les fibres de bois ont gonflé et se sont
densifié les termites et autres
nuisibles ont disparu du coup ce bois
souvent centenaire est plus sol
plus en revanche la couleur du bois qui
est resté sous l'eau pendant 30 ans
n'est pas aussi jolie que celle du bois
des
forêts le marché du bois précieux est en
pleine expansion nous exportons à bon
prix en Thaïlande à taiïwan au Japon et
en
Chine chaque jour à bateaux décharg leur
cargaison l'équipement est des plus
somma rue obsolète tracte directement le
bois depuis le
bateau les mesures de sécurité sont
quasiment
inexistantes et chaque année on déplore
de nombreux accidents graves d à la
chute des
bois je décharge les trons selon leur
taille et leur qualité quand on regarde
comme ça on a l'impression que c'est en
désordre mais en fait quand on connaî le
bois on trouve ce qu'on
cherche devant moi c'est les bois
tendres ils sont moins chers que les
bois
durs les plus rares sont les variétés
d'ében de palicandre de Padou et de bois
de rose bien
sûr il faut qu'on travaille vite si on
oublie de faire attention le bois peut
nous tomber dessus donc c'est très
dangereux il faut qu'on soit prudent
tout le temps
mais je commence à vooir de
[Musique]
l'expérience
quand on amène les trons de bois depuis
les profondeurs jusqu'au bord du lac il
faut les partager entre les différents
camions les différentes entreprises et
les
[Applaudissements]
siries moi ce que je souhaite c'est
gagner de l'argent j'économise pour ma
mère qui est pauvre et puis un jour je
me marierai j'espère que je n'aurai pas
trop de difficulté pour
vivre pendant que le bateau barge
retourne à vide vers les lieux de coupe
un comptable prend en charge les trons
et procède à leur marquage en fonction
de leur qualité et
gabarit je suis responsable de la mesure
des rondins je va à ce qu'il n ait pas
de liti entre le client et les
propriétaires des bateaux j'écris les
reçuétabl la comptabilité du bois et sa
répartion je vérifie les payes aussi ça
représente beaucoup de chiffres et
beaucoup de travail parce que c'est ici
qu'arrive tout le bois du
lac avant il y avait beaucoup de grands
rondins et puis ils ont commencé à
disparaître et maintenant il ne reste
plus que des petits tout a déjà été
nettoyé dans ce
lac
l'engouement pour les bois précieux
exotiques ne date pas d'hier la plupart
des pays d'Asie Thaïlande et Cambodge en
tête ont été en grande partie déboisés
au Laos les essences rares se trouvent
la plupart du temps dans des forêts
accessibles uniquement à dos d'éléphant
au prix de grands
effort dans ce contexte il n'est pas ins
sensé d'aller couper du bois sous l'eau
par 40 m de fond
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le bois du lac est de bonne qualité en
plus il y a beaucoup de variétés les
bois tendes sont utilisé pour la
décoration des maisons ou pour la
construction quant au bois solide et dur
il servent pour le mobilier et part
souvent à
l'exportation il est inutile de faire
sécher le bois du lac au soleil ce qui
nous permet de le débiter dès qu'il
arrive à la différence du bois des
forêts on peut l'exporter sans avoir à
le
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
traiter
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
OL Laos pays communiste les populations
vivent de peu tout est bon pour
améliorer son
ordinaire
aujourd'hui le bois exotique trône dans
tous les salons
occidentaux pourtant personne n'imagine
qu'à l'autre bout du monde des hommes
ont pris tous les risques pour ramener
ces bois précieux des
[Musique]
profondeurs non non non tout ça c'est
normal je n'ai pas peur sous l'eau ce
sont les autres qui ont peur pour moi je
habitué moi je me balade ici comme dans
une
[Musique]
forêt Nôi ta KH Khân
Thu VI Nam h
th kè C
thnương
nng x lu M
đu
đang